yesterday jj jj uh
it's time bud it's time
jj's got to walk out like goldberg with
all the [ __ ] security guards now
gilberg you mean um he's closer to
gilbert than yes goldberg
um let me let me get let me get them on
what up how the f do i follow that you
bring me on after that
destruction of a [ __ ] hobo man
i'll be i'll be honest with you bud i
didn't get a chance to watch the video
beforehand
i never do either it was it that was but
again wouldn't you
of course you could you're the one that
brought this you're the one that [ __ ]
cultivated dustin so obviously i mean
um i'm proud i'm a proud local papa
right now
that dude what a promo right what a
[ __ ] promo he cut
yeah i seen the talent early he's gonna
go far folks
what a [ __ ] promo he cut so
yesterday can i can i say something
please fellow fat guy bearded
[ __ ] please please
[Music]
just i want everybody to remember one
thing if you don't want it on the
internet don't put it there
all right sorry continue well fair
enough
uh so
this is uh yesterday we jj brought
somebody to our attention
um address address dia i just how do you
say it
do you know what whatever her name is
yeah yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what
i call her
old male head yeah mayor head works so
old mayo had
apparently somehow and i don't know i'm
assuming it was one of my zombie squad
people
uh told them that uh
told them told her that we may have been
talking about her
so she decided to make
not one not two
but three videos three
[ __ ] videos about us
um the first one is called
responding to day wave part one part one
when you hear part one you know there's
going to be a part two and a three
and three oh boy here we go
hey buddy can you uh sure i did did i
not
no so this is responding to day wave
part one i was alerted
alerted morning video that
was made about me essentially it's
this man and his friends just
ridiculing me you know that man name is
jj stoner let me tell you something i
disavow him
not just about him too [ __ ] [ __ ] a
guy [ __ ] that guy
now i didn't watch the whole video yes
she did
yeah i could tell you from watching
these videos
that she absolutely watched the whole
video or i didn't and i didn't watch any
of his other videos to know
like if they just go um if they just go
on women or if they make fun of men too
but why is it always immediately
[ __ ] turning into [ __ ] hating on
women i look i paid on
i probably make fun of more men than i
do women to be honest with you
i like to say i'm an equal opportunity
hater yeah exactly
yes
so i wanted to make a video addressing
it
okay because they're all on your phone
that's how she makes all our videos a
lot of new subscribers thanks to it
you're welcome hello you're well i mean
all i wanted to thank you
um my last count there was about 15 of
you
that joined up in the last hour
and i'm fully aware that you're here to
make fun of me and laugh at me
i think everyone is all 260 people
yeah that's about right um
i wanted to i'm gonna answer
a couple of the things that came up in
the video right off
and then i'll actually watch the video
and uh i'll respond to a couple of
other things from there because i'm
aware that this is gonna be a long video
because they talked about
me specifically for over half an hour
it was like 40 minutes she got the clip
this is day two of it though yeah
oh that's right that was the h d a g d
clip was talking about it jj
the whole clip was on our cliff channel
okay
sorry um
all right so one of the videos that they
mentioned was
when i first moved into my section 8 and
a man came into my apartment
and they were laughing and saying well
what's he going to steal you're just
moved in
you're going to love this we didn't say
what you're gonna steal you just moved
in
chat chat all right chat what if someone
could steal from this hobo's brand-new
house
what do you think her stolen mattress
stolen mattress so i can't guess because
i know the answer because i did
pre-watch a little of this i'm sorry
i'll guess uh duck carcasses duck
carcass
killer oh no [ __ ] 50 pound bags of
uncooked rice her
yeast filled [ __ ] the the [ __ ] on the
shower floor
her mayo shampoo
her lice motel
okay do we get all of them i think i
think we i think
yeah i think we're good okay good um
oh no no no no her nintendo her super
nintendo
not even the whole thing's just the
controller
[Laughter]
just the controller royce just the
controller
it's a classic that's your most valued
possession by the way
those are collectibles that's why
it doesn't even have the cord oh god
hold on i took some coffee i'm i need
i'm just
i'm befuddled did you stretch you're
gonna need to stretch
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] no she's doing all the
reaching for him
yeah well you know she's usually this is
what i was afraid that he would steal
if ever anybody breaks into my
my house domicile housing or my stuff
this is what i'm afraid that they're
going to take from me
this is an
8-bit dough game pad
that i use to game um
man i got an elite two xbox controller i
love it if anyone did steal it i'd
probably be mad too so on some level i
kind of understand this
but it doesn't have a cord to connect to
it that's what i don't have a cord
either it's
it's bluetooth ag that's not a wireless
controller that's a super nintendo
controller guys look it doesn't matter
what it is
it's a homeless lunatic that puts
mayonnaise in her hair
let's focus on let's focus on the thing
we need to focus on here
i'm so lost they stole my game boy
and my duck trophies yeah my [ __ ]
[ __ ] duck trophies and my game boys
oh my god in my crystal necklace that
doesn't move
it doesn't i swear to god it'll never
move
you think it's like fused to her skin it
has to be dude it's been in the same
place for
like six months if you go to my channel
you'll notice that i am attempting
to be a gamer i recently finished
earthbound
which was much easier with is that a new
game
yeah it's what the kids are playing
nowadays you know
like 25 years ago more
well then she said it wrong she should
be a retro gamer right
than it would have been playing on the
on the digital pad
um that controller cost me over fifty
dollars
last year fifty buckaroonies huh
gonna say that [ __ ] elite two is like
180
when i got the first stimulus that we
got
i invested and i got myself that
okay buying a it's like
buying a super nes isn't an investment
hey royce i think i figured out how she
ended up with no money by friday yeah
i'm figuring it out too
at least dustin bought nice skirts yeah
i mean they're reusable you know yeah
you could just [ __ ] close
so she's [ __ ] she's so she thinks
this was going to get her out of the
hole becoming a [ __ ] earthbound gamer
on collectibles yes i mean i think
dustin will make it further with his
skirt collection
well dustin has championship collectible
belts dust rings
dustin has a personality yeah like that
right there already beats this
so that i could start my youtube gaming
uh
uh because i was i just want to point
something out here guys we're like only
two minutes in
yeah trying to you know find a way to
make
an income for myself so that i wouldn't
just be
begging for everything forever not
hating on that good idea
good she's working oh that's what i was
afraid
that he was going to steal is this
if anything was going to be stolen it
would be this
i think we can replace that for if it
ever gets stolen i'm just saying
i promise you something if anything ever
happens i'll make the solemn vow i will
buy you a new one
okay because we know you're watching
mary yeah we know you're watching mary
i'll buy you a new one how about that
okay
i'll tell you what all right you want
controllers we can get you like you play
co-op with like the [ __ ]
i don't know the mattress maybe you know
what you know what i'll do
the ducks i'll get you guys i'll i'll
get you a nintendo switch
okay so you can see you can play on the
go
when inevitably get kicked out of this
house you could play it on this
on your tent we should set her up with
nomad sam they could let him know that
they could both live in your van huh
they're both both in california crazy
well i think
i just don't go with me here like don't
hold me this but i think it would have
to be nomads samantha for this to work
we don't know what sam's got under the
hood well he does like to wear dresses
too so i don't know man i don't know
wait you think she's uh you think she
um ah you know i'm gonna say she has a
hatred for men
she does yeah that admit on top of that
so i don't i don't know if she likes
penis anymore
um so i can only assume you know the
other way because there's only two right
oh wait never mind
no there's like 36 dude give a [ __ ]
kiss 87 come on i don't want to get
caught
get kicked off of youtube yeah sorry
sorry susan i mean
suzanne or whatever the [ __ ] you mean
her name's sam now
sam what i was really upset about was
just the fact that he thought it was
okay to walk into my apartment
and it wasn't like y'all said he just
poked the
his head in we we didn't do that we
never said that
yeah well no i probably said that
because i said he probably just did that
assuming because she only made a video
of her talking about the experience
oh you're right good point good point i
don't know i don't know it wasn't a
filmed experience i only went off of
what she said
he like i was leaving
for the day i had my mask on
had my keys in my hand and i had a 30
pound bag of rice to go murder more
ducks
i forgot my wallet so but
honestly what could have possibly been
in it
i opened the door ebt card oh that's
true
your amazon card or to go out realize
i've forgotten my wallet
let go of the door and walk over to the
counter to grab the wallet right so the
door is like
it's not open stop saying wallet but
it's not fully closed either it's just
kind of
wedged so it's a very short walk
i can't imagine it's palatial from the
door to the kitchen island where i was
at when i turned around again
he was standing inside he had pushed the
door open
and stepped inside and told me that it
was because
uh he thought a homeless person had
gotten in there well they told
me technically i mean technically
he wasn't wrong we all butted our heads
every we all we all
[ __ ] came in with our heads down on
that one yeah obviously
and he was right so you can't blame the
guy i thought a homeless person got in
there
but yeah why would she's like she's like
why would you think a homeless woman
came here because i come here with a
shopping cart full of empty cans
is that why it's the mattress yeah
or is it the mattress that i dragged up
here that has [ __ ] bed bugs on it
what is it i mean i'm just saying like
he was a concerned neighbor this is
exactly what me and kitty said
it was a concerned neighbor that knew
that place was empty and was like oh
[ __ ] there's someone in here [ __ ]
[ __ ] up
that's all this was and that i
it it made me feel uncomfortable it made
me feel violated
it made me feel angry
okay you know i literally just moved in
and people are already
coming in and saying well i i thought it
was okay i thought
somebody else the guy walked in and he
was like oh i'm so sorry i thought this
was a shower i needed to take a [ __ ]
i uh uh my lady and then he walked like
he said he goes milady and then he
walked out
have a blessed day and then he went on
to go [ __ ] in the communal shower
christ and so then they're talking about
how
with my tents people used to um come in
and say that
it was their tent and they're saying
well all tents look alike so that's
the first of that's racism and i'm not
gonna put up with that on this show okay
all tents matter plausible
my tent was always off away from
everybody else's
i she's a loner she's a lone wolf she's
an alpha woman
oh god i intentionally put my stuff
away from other people's stuff
so that there wouldn't be a reason for
them to get confused and go into the
wrong tent
like a lot of them out there they're
lined up you can see like 10 in a row
and yeah
it's going to be confusing when there's
10 doorways to go through
i was by myself there was never i
i doubt that with your charming
personality
my other problem here like you're
talking about alcoholic and drug addicts
trying to remember something
okay stop it the tent looks the same
they're gonna be like oh it's my tent
yeah i don't think there's a big there's
a huge amount of mutual respect in the
homeless community
no especially from you know annoying
people
i know what you were going to say i'm
with you i cut it off because i don't
want to get your channel banned i'm like
you [ __ ] they were trying to take me
down the other night 2010 jj would have
said something completely different
2010 they would have spent five minutes
explaining to you how she really
is that person you know
another tent beside me because if
somebody tried to put up beside me
i would are you saying she's a reverse
oreo at jj
agreement them i'm not social
you're not she's not social that's
really weird for somebody that keeps
posting on
social media i'd scream at them if they
park their tent next to mine you're
alone
this is get out of my backyard ma'am
you're under a bridge
you're next to the railroad tracks and
that's the only place the city can't
kick you out
freaking seriously
okay so another thing that was mentioned
also i'd like to point out to you men
oh she really does hate men huh men i
mean you know better than i do jj but
she hates men right
yeah man all of them that it's
kind of punching down to be attacking
somebody
who's in the position that i'm in
no no no no no no okay i want to make
this barely
very clear i don't i understand it's
punching down
but when you have this amount of mental
illness
and this amount of public outcry on the
internet you must be observed
that is what i'm all about observing the
crazy people so we know
their next move well and i also identify
as a um
trans black man so i am extremely high
on the victim scale so sweetie you're a
white woman you don't get to tell me
what to do
i don't like this white woman talking
out of hispanic guy either i i really
don't feel like that i
my struggle is real
i i have mental disorders that i'm very
open about
no [ __ ] and like at one point somebody
said
cptsd is like not real or something
no no no no no no nobody said that
nobody said that said that but
but we think you're lying about it we
believe i believe that it's real
i just don't think you have it all right
because if you
if you did where did you serve i saw the
guy get
scared at the fireworks the veteran next
are you scared of fireworks
what are you a german the only people
the only people the only people scared
of fireworks are german shepherds and
[ __ ]
soldiers
it's mean it's really mean dogs [ __ ]
really mean
um we i just want to point out we're
only five minutes in
yeah by the way there's another video
that's longer double well don't forget
the middle video there's just two more
oh yeah
there's there's so much uh
compound post traumatic stress disorder
is real compound yeah yeah that's that's
where you scream the n word at a black
lady wonder why they kick you out of
sirius
i think
that was savage i'm sorry
it was there you go hey make me play
take a sip of my coffee
that was worth it take a sip go ahead
throw the arm up
[Music]
relax all right
and they're making fun of me because i
hit the trifecta
of mental illnesses and the hat trick
i have a lot of mental issues you know
i'm not
i don't think i've ever denied that you
know
it doesn't change they're saying that i
spend all my money on hair dye
and mayonnaise
i [ __ ] need that what's the time
stamp 614
614 bud
i spent all my money
[Music]
this is gonna take two hours
oh that's elbow laugh number two of the
show no i can't i think i was bad
that's so you know i'm really laughing
hard when i turn into elmo
full elbows oh [ __ ]
she's highly today's show is brought to
you by the letter h
for homeless
okay oh [ __ ]
focus everyone guys fellas i need you to
[ __ ]
all right we get through this we're
gonna
we're gonna end up with [ __ ] compound
media ptsd and i don't want that
let's go let me show you all the hair
dye situation i'd rather you not
this is my current bottle of hair dye
right well maybe she didn't want the
dessert
to buy to see her hair dye either
maybe the [ __ ] ramones we're going to
break into her apartment and steal her
hair
or every emo 12 year old
i got this at christmas
merry christmas i'm only using it you
sure it's not hanukkah
about i don't know once every two weeks
and only on the very front of my hair
because it doesn't have to be mixed with
the chemical
it it can be reused and saved
this bottle will last me probably the
rest of the year
if i make it hey man that's great have
you tried you know since you're homeless
not dyeing your hair
i mean look she's allowed to dye her
hair just like go cheaper get the
kool-aid you're not [ __ ] seriously
bleach yeah peroxide you know
so no no she can't use bleach she just
has someone else to scare her so it
turns white
that's free i'm not spending all my
money on hair dye maybe once or twice a
year
i buy bottles and normally i go to sally
and i buy
the discounted bottles and that's why my
hair is sometimes just rainbow colored
because i'll find a bottle of blue
for very cheap and then that bottle will
last me for a while and i'll wind up
with blue hair for a while
it's not that i'm spending all my money
on hair dye but
i like to look nice i said that i said
that you spent money you gave a hundred
dollars to some lady on the internet
that you didn't even know and we found
out you spent 50
on a game controller yeah which again
you're perfectly entitled to have these
things if you
had a job and had your own money but
you're using government money to do this
so
that's the problem she's living in
government housing
has an ebd ebt card they're paying for
everything for you sweetie
yeah so i mean shut up and and let us
make fun of you because this is as
famous as you're ever gonna get trust me
we're honestly helping you yeah trust me
being homeless that's not easy
well neither is pimping but the
godfather did it
you should get her on the hoe train are
you kidding me
the hobo train she's [ __ ] riding the
rails
sam could be the new godfather
a hobo train
[Laughter]
so they were also laughing at me for
crying about not being able to take a
shower
because it was [ __ ] hilarious it's
kind of funny clean the tub
it's not rocket science yeah seriously
um
all right so that started that happened
that was last year that was in the
beginning
of the pandemic like literally when
cobits first started
for a full year before that
i had been getting showers primarily
at my doctor's office i went twice a
month
so hold on she was prescribed showers
yes that's right
it's terrible to be able to be
prescribed shower
take two of these and call me in the
morning take two of these and stop
scratching your head
see my doctor once and then two weeks
later i would see my therapist and then
two weeks later i would see my doctor
right
so every two weeks i was getting a
shower
so when the covid regulations came and
stopped it the first thing that happened
was my therapist cancelled my
appointment
so i missed a shower then and then when
i went in for the doctor's appointment
they informed me that i wasn't able to
get a shower anymore because they were
because they said that i had and i'm not
going to say this lightly
lit here but they said i had a kept
leaving a jungle musk
in the shower and they don't want
anybody else to go in there
two weeks of hobo funk coming off they
had to send in a hazmat team after
seriously
let's hope opie doesn't see her he'll
make her sing creep and then put it on
youtube
we're shutting them down for health
regulations hey maybe well i mean i know
that guy's dead but hey mayo and mustard
that could have been something right
mayo and oh my god you're right mayo and
mustard
that would have been perfect and i still
don't understand
how it's going to keep the how it's
going to keep the population healthy
to take away the showers from the
homeless and i but why do you think
you're entitled to it like that's the
thing i don't understand
we should there's like lakes and rivers
in l.a right no
no no no the the the only thing that has
water is the thing right the terminator
rode his motorcycle in the red yeah but
that's still water right
but the most of them are dirty water
most of them are fenced off because the
reservoirs are the drinking water and we
wouldn't want the homeless
showering or bathing in the drinks
but what they could do is like china you
know that spray they were spraying for
kovid
they could just drive down skid row and
spray them all with that powder [ __ ]
get mobile hose trucks that's what we
need fire trucks we have them already
they're called fire trucks we just
drive dude that's what they're called
cool sorry
you you already have everything in
california man california sounds like
you guys have everything figured we're
utopia out there dude
we got a million homeless people i got
upset
because they were saying it's only going
to be for a couple of weeks when you
come back next month you'll be able to
get your shower
when i get back and i said in that video
it might not be
over in a couple of weeks that's not how
i was
not good she's right you know right
there with you we're pissed about the
lockdowns too lady we're with you we
honestly are her phone's going up five
percent
but you know oh that's right she must be
charging her phone because it has gone
up five percent since this video so
hey charge watch we're keeping an eye on
for you versus work
that's just not it's just not plausible
to believe that that's how they work
so i knew way back when this started
that this could have gone on for months
years and i said that decades even in
the video this could go on for
months and it did it wound up being
five months before i was able to get a
full shower
in a hotel room like with an actual
shower i was bathing myself
if you go through my video i think one
of her friends kate brownsie is in the
chat
you could tell that's not a normal
listener what does it matter with you
guys
seriously i don't know we like laughing
at people you got a problem
i mean interesting people catch my
attention then i follow them around for
a little bit
i see how funny they could possibly be
and then i pass them
up to the larger shows that expose them
even further
and then also puts my name out at the
same time and then they
keep moving on and on and on and on and
that's how you get
attention it's the circle of life
the circle of cows
videos you'll see me um washing my hair
by pouring buckets of water over me
it gets better than [ __ ] mail yeah we
did that for als
like couple years ago i remember yeah we
did [ __ ] her real life is the als
challenge
but um so yeah that's what the situation
with the shower was
because y'all are given a lot of this
with no context at all
but i you know and i know if something's
funny it doesn't need context in fact
it's even funnier when it doesn't need
to be explained
what i'm wondering is is that how did
she get in this situation
like because you don't you're just not
homeless
she was a floridian who moved to
california all right
all right so there is a book all right
look i'll tell you what lady
there is a book she is a writer i
purchased the book so lady i've given
you five bucks
uh it is five dollars if you want it uh
kitty i think kitty has the link she's
awesome with [ __ ] like that
but uh the book is called i'll never
stop screaming
and if you would like to watch the full
reading of it it's actually
her reading it on her youtube channel
uh so um you can either buy it and throw
it five bucks or you can go watch it on
her youtube channel
that's yeah yeah kitty sammy send it to
me um
that'll be that'll explain how she got
to la
uh let me let's put a couple donations
here because i don't want people to
think
we're ignoring sorry that was a little
loud
roses are red violets are twisted bend
over sam you're about to get fisted
really good
a couple years ago they tried to build a
couple shower houses for the homeless
but they were protested because of
anti-semitism
makes sense that makes sense
i mean i don't know how but i'm assuming
it makes sense i just i'm going to say
it makes sense
because i want to get kicked off of
youtube it makes sense you're right
[ __ ] anti-semitic showers
troopers i just received new orders
these are semantics we could kill
everyone in ca
just all of them sorry sorry ag no what
we should do is just send the whole
country's homeless there and turn it
into like a refuge
house oh kind of like what cartman did
in south park yeah block it off
california super cool to the homeless
[Laughter]
hey just want to point out we're nine
minutes in hey we're in progress this
might be an eight part
another one percentage went up on our
phone though we're 52 now
all right yeah charge that [ __ ] i freak
out and i cry a lot i i do i am an
emotional human being
i think the words hey hey but you know
what
we're going to turn you into an
emotional human doing
yeah look at the turnaround on dustin
lady listen to us we'll fix you
yes please look dustin's turnaround was
like that
dustin's defending himself and his
entire zombie squad
dude thomas has become a functioning
member of society
mark lane is taking a [ __ ] r r break
for himself
just believe in us and we'll help you
and don't play the victim and everything
i'll have you walk in a runway in a year
it'll be the runway at lax but still
it's a runway
i mean all right i get it i was setting
up the video
my problem with it was that a year this
one's probably a four or five year
project but
i mean maybe maybe not i mean honestly
we're we're the [ __ ] the country's a
death spiral anyway
this is what half the left looks like so
you're good to go
yeah and you know at one point i said
that in the video and he questions it
which is hurtful because well
you know i often have trouble
feeling like a normal like
a person i don't i don't feel like i'm
i'm like you
[ __ ] welcome to the [ __ ] party pal
like
none of us feel normal all of us feel
weird
it's just how you deal with it right
yeah royce has a squeaky voice
and a bald head ag has a [ __ ] leg and a
fat forehead
i'm fat with a beard what's the point
why didn't we get the two hardest things
in here yeah yeah j.j
seemed to be the nicest on himself i'm
fat with the beer did you notice that jj
was the nicest i caught that a.g
jj was a nice cancer does it make you
feel better there we go
yes honestly it makes you feel a lot
better thank you
okay it makes me feel a lot better also
adonis paul said he'll have her walking
the streets in an hour
i believe that now whether she's
bringing in income that's a different
story but
[Laughter]
walking the street sure but you have to
worry about her getting bit by dogs
and homeless la mexican ladies
right i'm not and i know that
and so to have somebody like just
openly questioning whether i'm actually
a human being and telling me that i look
like an alien
no one said that who said she looked
like an alien
it wasn't me i mean now that i'm looking
at her i can see why she means says that
but
i'm not i kind of looks like roger but i
don't think she looks like an alien not
not that much
no no she looks like a hobo yeah yeah
you are what you eat or if you think i'm
ugly i don't care if you want to compare
me and say
i look like a man i'm fine with that i
really am
no you're not it's when you're saying
that i look like animals
and extraterrestrial beings and things
that
aren't even human that just
didn't she just say she wasn't human
am i the only one oh i don't know i
don't remember saying
anything about she looked like an animal
like she just said
i'm not human i don't act like a human
being i'm
detached from humanity essentially and
she's mad that you guys called her an
animal
i have been pointed out several times
don't look at her teeth stop looking at
her teeth that makes her uncomfortable
yeah i i don't i i've avoided them
purposely
she looks very british because i've
spent my whole life
being treated like i'm not a real person
all right pinocchio
like [ __ ] girl yes seriously oh
boy come on like
when i was a kid my parents didn't
really buy me stuff because
my grandmother took care of me and so
your grandparents bought you stuff
meanwhile did so they would say well mom
meemaw will take
she'll get it and we don't we don't have
to buy mary birthday presents
or christmas presents because she has me
mom so you're homeless because your
parents didn't buy you gifts
i'm not even gonna lie homie we got a
rich grandma in my family too
so what the [ __ ] like you know
what what do you want me to say the
[ __ ] people people some people have
money some people don't and
in your family that's gonna be that way
too like
yeah welcome to america it's gonna get
worse now
and it was like i wasn't a member of the
family i wasn't one of their children
because you didn't get gifts
i guess that's a [ __ ] weird thought
process right
hey royce can we get her some [ __ ]
birthday gifts no i really
am i'm not even kidding you and i mean
this sincerely because if all you need
is gifts
i will buy you presents if it makes you
stop putting mayonnaise in your hair and
murdering ducks
because that seems [ __ ] fair to me
and constantly being the victim
all right hey hey hey don't kill the
content cow let her keep being the
victim all right
okay sorry hey gg here's the thing
nothing's going to stop her from being
the victim well i understand that but
you're saying she could win the lottery
right now and she'll be a victim
okay but still don't don't kill the
content cow if she was if she did
win the lottery by next week she'd be
broke again oh yeah she
she'd [ __ ] spend it all on [ __ ]
rice and
[ __ ] shower [ __ ] i think i figured it
out why she thinks that we're calling
her an animal because i keep calling her
a low cow she doesn't understand what
local no low cut doesn't mean you're an
animal
you're a person it just means you're
funny and milkable
you you get under there and get those
letters i don't
i don't like nice sized teats i don't
like the implication that i'm not even a
human being
that's hurtful no one's you know
no one said that i'm trying to think if
there was anything
oh my
my thumbnail what did you do my
thumbnail is your day way thumbnail
and then it's a cow because it's a but
that but again it's a little cow that
doesn't mean she's a cow
but she doesn't know that she's not you
have to explain these things to it so
look mary she's watching it now yeah
well you're watching this we did not
locale is not calling you a literal cow
it is just saying that you
are making you have a lot of videos
where like your your hot takes are
milkable for elves lols do you know what
those are lulls
it's part of what the kids use and the
slang terms nowadays i say keck
yeah it's yeah damn i see look
this is why you don't need context
because if you have to explain it it's
not funny or it's not worth the time
particularly i wanted to question
uh our answer i mean yeah there is the
hiv thing
wait hold on this is new to me no jj did
say that yesterday
does she have hiv i don't i'm not again
the story is that she had sex with a guy
that had
uh hiv aids or whatever the [ __ ] and
that she
made it to the uh to the doctor to get
the pill
uh i guess the pill that magic johnson
helped create oh
okay that kills aids instantly so
there's no chance once you take this
pill there's no chance that aids stays
dormant inside of you was it leeches was
it was the pill just a [ __ ] mixture
of mayonnaise and kerosene
no i think it was a mixture of money and
water if you
remember yeah so they're saying that i
allegedly took this medication to not
get hiv
after dating you said that i can't say
his name he'll sue me
um magic johnson hold on
but all those things are true but we'll
sue you for what
her controller pro controller her
controller and her hair dye
and mayonnaise yeah and manny not even
the dukes kindness the [ __ ] kind too
hey mary get dukes next time it's
probably better i can't afford that
all right let's get her some dukes next
we'll get her a switch
she understands some [ __ ] good hair
dye maybe a little bit of makeup
yeah why are we doing adonis paul to put
his woman on the street
there is a medication you probably have
not heard of it
because it's not really well known
but this was a couple of years ago um
and
the medication works if you get it
in your system within 72 hours
of coming in contact with the virus
attempted to infect me because this was
a deliberate
he was deliberately attempting to affect
infect me
of course he was um
he had been on his medication for a very
long time
and it was unrecognizable which means
it's more
it's it's harder to even pass it
sexually
oh i've seen that movie it was called
dallas panhandlers club
it was uh for sure yeah i'm pretty sure
that was matthew mcconaughey it was
section 8
rent that's section 8 that's what it was
i get it yeah yeah yeah
loaded has it did she get it from the
mayo clinic
yeah that's a good hey look he might be
[ __ ] but sometimes he gets us angry
one if she wouldn't have been in
california it would have been against
the law
yeah well that i think that was in
california or uh florida at that point
again i have a long timeline of her
because like this is like month
four following her around it's stalking
no it's not she put it up on the
youtubes on the social media i'm just
being so
kate which i'm assuming is her friend
you guys know nothing about her frankly
i don't really either only that she has
shared on youtube she is really open
about her mental illness
why do you as grow men need to make fun
of totally kate isn't her
yeah why yeah why did why do you you
know it's her right
why do you always grow up and need to
make fun of someone you don't even know
um because we have to fill time in the
show i had two hours
welcome to the internet [ __ ] yeah and
you put you put things on the internet i
said
i started this off with don't put it on
the internet if you don't what it made
fun of
that's why and if you need any more
reason than that then i don't know if i
can help you
not her yeah totally married
um but we still went to the doctor and
got me on the medication within the 72
hours
i took them and i've been tested
multiple times since then because
um my ex-husband has hiv and
so every time that you had sex with your
husband you took the 72-hour pill
well was her ex-husband the guy who
exposed her and she meant to not say
who it was and she just did to her she
was married
yeah shocking right
i can't believe it
like uh 10 years well okay
when he was diagnosed with hiv way back
in like
2008 and that man was charlie sheen
maybe 2009 um they were telling us that
it could be
dormant in your system for 10 years so
you need to be checked every six months
and when
blah tried to infect me in 2017
16.
so hold on she she married someone who
was hiv positive
and then tried to get infected by
someone who is hiv positive
it's called chasing the bug the bug
chaser
she does seem like she wants the gift uh
maybe that's why she got the she flipped
the mattress over she had to feel at
home i mean quite possibly i i don't
know
gross 16.
she she [ __ ] we don't know her she
doesn't even know her
yeah i don't know we don't know her okay
do you understand that the more i get to
know her the worse it is right
the easier to laugh at like
did she marry him because he had hiv did
she marry
did he find it at hiv after she married
him how did he get
hiv see look all right
i i know you guys know the red bars but
uh the red bar calls this part
discovery okay so that's what we're
discovering
this woman as we go got it it's like
like illegal i get my years mixed up
so do i he
the the doctors then told me that um
stop taking a shower in our sink
why are you [ __ ] in our sink could
be dormant in your system for three
years
they had advanced the medication they
had advanced
the testing so that it's only
if you come in contact with it if you
took these pills within 72 hours
it could kill the virus completely
before it actually
gets into your system if you don't get
it within the 72 hours
it can still possibly like um be killed
i think that our video was shared in
some sort of little group that they had
yeah i'm starting to notice i'm i'm
looking at the i'm looking at some of
the names
i'm looking at some of the names in here
these are new names
and um i'm starting to feel like and
they're women of course
oh yeah and i'm starting to figure out
that there was this video may have been
shared in the little internal facebook
group
possible uh so i want to say hi potus
hey maybe you could read her book i'm a
widowed mother of two boys so i don't
really have time to read but i better go
tell you in her book
i have read her book i gave her five
dollars okay
i've read her book in her book she only
explained
that she's had problems with her family
and that she [ __ ]
did all the aids stuff is not in the
book okay
i think i mean you did you you read her
book on air right the whole thing i read
her whole book on air
nice i even read the book with her
oh nice because she doesn't ought she
does audio books royce
oh that makes even better she has a she
has a full reading of her book on her
name
yeah like we we can go through she reads
wizard of oz we can we can do wizard of
oz with her
see this is what happens when you put
things on the internet okay
but you wouldn't even i do want to
escape to neverland because
i'm a huckleberry says whoa there's
babes in the chat
hey what's up ladies careful they're
gonna think that we're trying to uh
what's that song that
the on the first date thing what's that
i don't want to get accused of that
thank you
yes no you don't want you you don't want
to you don't want to become a sublime
song
no no
for sure whether or not you were safe
you know date rape should have really
been written that's the song date rape
should remember a name to mind your
business
um sorry uh it's been about three years
and i've
been tested i didn't get tested last
year because of the covet stuff
i've been planning on going as soon as
the
clinics open up again to get the testing
done um
oh yeah you know what that's a good
point we got some donations here let's
get to some of these
shoot them up ride
someone tell hank azaria that he can get
regular showers if he moves to live with
the rest
of the homeless people at the beach also
how did he blow all his simpson's money
it's not hanka's
but you know what nick god damn it man
now that i'm looking at it
i see hank azaria a little bit i really
do
since i have to relive this pink blob
homeless chick story are we all gonna
remember who
build sioux city
build sioux city on rock and roll
[Music]
and don't go to sioux city all right
bali bali i know you hate me because i
destroyed your [ __ ] and [ __ ]
bellheim last night but we need we built
this city on slab city
and we needed like an edit with all the
slab city [ __ ]
and then they built this slab city yes
troopers i just received new orders
uh boohoo crimea river trail of tears
lady
huh give me one more we have one more
come on yeah man
[Music]
crew to the homeless
[Music]
i don't think carmelo likes us carmel
says so you make money publicly shaming
mentally disabled people excuse me
you [ __ ] [ __ ] all right number one
stop watching or you're gonna fall in
love with me
and number two i have
helped out dustin i've helped i've
taught i've
given thomas money i've bought dust and
skirts and
a fishing pole for his buddy justin
who's getting bullied i'm actually the
protector of these people
i'll have you know e-frog you want us to
keep
oh yeah e-frog my buddy e frog who lost
his wife
so you could say a lot of taking it with
ben kicking it with [ __ ] ben
you can say a lot of things about me but
you can't say that
okay nice try you don't you say we don't
know enough about her
you don't know enough about me carmella
and honestly you better [ __ ] stop
i'm not gonna date you so cut it out all
right i'll stop hitting on me we'll only
do that for
for for a minute apparently yes you're
right
um maybe that says something about women
it does it's weird it's the [ __ ]
weird victim but
also think about it this way you've
picked on more guys because you picked
on these guys originally and then you
came to
get to know them so you've picked on
more guys than you have women
when it comes to these kind of crazy
people on the internet do you remember
binary bible
remember binary bible now hold on hold
on
because that she didn't really consider
herself a woman she was more of a butch
oh like yeah but she's a woman and
there's a vagina there
look there's a [ __ ] or if you're a
chick so but anyway binary bible she was
one that we goofed on a little bit
and then we criticized her and then she
actually says you know what maybe i do
remember that she made a video saying
maybe i do kind of make it about myself
all the time i want to be better
and then we had her call into the show
and now we're friends now we actually
are friends
you know parker if you come back and
check in on her she's doing better
she is you know honestly i did check in
a couple weeks ago
she's doing way better you're her you're
these people's primary protector
you're their their d.i.d guy i'm the did
yes kyle i'm the
kyle also the how how are these people
coming in here when they don't realize
that you have d.i.d
it's honestly kind of messed up i also
have a mental illness okay
and on top of that i was born with what
doctors call a [ __ ] head
so honestly you guys are making fun of
me for no [ __ ]
honestly you're putting me down and you
can't see below my waist
i have no legs and i have one arm so on
top of all that i'm a multiple amputee
you're taking my bit now yeah i was
gonna say uh royce do you realize that
everybody on this call has [ __ ]
forehead itis yes we all have [ __ ]
heads in here
so honestly you making fun of us and by
the way you're assuming i'm a man
you don't know what i [ __ ] you don't
know what i identify as
i already had told everyone i'm a i'm a
black trans woman he's a black trans
woman
all right royce i've seen the shoe so
yo that's all that's good now good shoe
fair enough
but yeah those medications you can look
it up
you know i'm not lying about those
existing
they make you real sick though um you
know what else makes you real sick
[Laughter]
and apparently jj's channeling bob levy
yeah the old lady's home that's around
the same time
that my hair started falling out and i
started getting real
sick and i think that it i think that
those pills are part
of what messed my system up really
really really badly
well it could be the aids
oh also somebody mentioned my thyroid
that i probably need to get my thyroid
checked and
yes i never mentioned that did somebody
i think she read chat
oh she's talking about reading okay well
i can't be responsible for what the chat
says
lady you can't blame us for the savages
in the [ __ ] chat room yeah this isn't
d live i can't be responsible for what
the chat does
let's do i haven't had a chance um
it's hard to get into the doctor if
you're not dying at the moment it's not
that hard
i live in california as a californian i
can tell you it's not that hard to get
into an urgent care or anywhere else
right now so you can keep making excuses
i literally got in for a cancer
appointment okay i've been died during
this
diagnosed so what the [ __ ] no your yours
is more
death like i've had friends who you
could die from it you know like i've had
friends who
have gone into urgent care and elsewhere
it's it's not as hard as she wants to
make it out to be
like i'd want you to go to the doctor jj
even if there was a pandemic
i have i've been going this is how you
go to the doctor
you get the doctor and then the doctor
says go to this doctor then you go to
that doctor of course she's going to the
doctor where else is jj showering
i have a house man anyways uh this one i
think it's her problem is she finds a
reason not to go cause that there was
one video i remember her making a couple
weeks ago that she was like i'm not
going to the doctor because i'm getting
my stove delivered or some [ __ ] like
that
yeah so what jj jj has cancer don't make
a big deal about it i honestly don't
like that the child was making this big
deal about it who cares
he'll be fine i don't even care about it
he's fine he'll be fine
it was it was it was butt whole candy
and if he's not gonna be fine he's not
gonna be fine
it's not [ __ ] butthole cancer yeah
you know who else had [ __ ] cancer
roman reigns and he was wwe champion
yeah he [ __ ] is wwe champion yeah so
i mean
come on so you're telling us now that jj
has cancer he's going to be wwe champion
that's
look if i'm doing my math correctly i
believe so like
[ __ ] bray wyatt could win the
championship someday yeah someday
vince is just going to go down to
wherever jj's at see carmella you feel
pretty stupid now that somebody on the
call is cancer and you're [ __ ]
talking about us
you feel good about yourself chance but
i i do need to get my thyroid checked
because i like randomly pass
out and have blood sugar issues and i've
it's called diabetes
yeah that's diabetes get on metformin it
works for me
stop eating sugar and bread but i'm
gonna well no actually coincidentally
don't stop eating sugar and bread i got
yelled at last time i went to the doctor
because i stopped eating sugar and bread
and they were like hey it's too low
so oh yeah
off and go over to the video and let
y'all see
for yourself what they're saying
so hold on she's going to yours this is
going to be a long video
just she's going over to the actual 15
minutes
now all right does she go to yours or
the clip channel uh clip channel i think
oh no hoping that it won't freeze like
the other one
no she went to your actual oh no it's
minus wow
i don't know how to like make sure it
doesn't all right cool
this is cool this is the gentleman that
is going to be
discussing my life today i'm gonna turn
my face off
that'll help yes there's always a better
day when i go away
anyways she got she even
self-deprecating joke
i like this guy yeah this guy over here
is pretty good looking dude hey what's
up bud
high five oh
there it is
there it is he's struggling with my name
yeah well sorry your name has 37 vowels
in it
all right i got it now
hey frozen you're on the screen
congratulations you're famous
i didn't know because i didn't know what
music i need to play is she gangsta
victim
[Laughter]
maureen
so this particular one right here
hold on man i just got smacked for
someone saying something in the other
chat that you're playing in the video
over there
thanks [ __ ] from yesterday yeah you
[ __ ] dick
there's so many chat screens going on
right now it's crazy
i'll send it to you we're in mirror
world
[Music]
so i'm just wanting to break in
it's not an awful book i mean
kind of feels like an awful book you
know when it comes to my book the
criticisms about my book i would prefer
if the criticism came from somebody
that's actually read it or at least
listen
jj's read the [ __ ] book i read the
whole [ __ ] book that's on my d live
channel for like the last
three [ __ ] weeks are you kidding me
none of the book has any of the age [ __ ]
it's all about meemaw and how
her family sucks it's not it has nothing
about the aids segment
maybe if she wrote book number two i'll
give her five bucks for that too
because the aids awakening
i'm not um stop hating that's what you
need to name the second one
seriously philadelphia two rides are the
machines
writer i'm not trained i barely well i'm
not a cat
so hey [ __ ] poop in the charlotte
thank you very much
through high school right um i never
said that i was the greatest but
for a book published by
somebody who has never had any writing
training or anything like that i don't
think it's awful right
i didn't say it was awful jj never said
the book was awful
it was hard to read but the content was
fantastic yeah it was actually a good
book
well that's just my opinion maybe i'm
[ __ ] biased
i'm working on a second one oh
can i do something here i'm going to do
something here because i did this binary
bible to this okay
i know you're listening to this whatever
your name is lmnop
yes day here's what we're going to do
no because i want to be fair because i
really want to be fair
why don't you
why don't you come on my show
there it is and i will talk to you and i
will let you get your side of all of
this i've done this before
and i've turned out becoming pretty good
friends with some of these people so
i'm fair i will be fair please i welcome
you
i welcome you to come on my show now
you come on my show we'll have a nice
conversation
and you could ask people you could ask
around i'm not going to ambush you i'm
not going to [ __ ] i don't do that
[ __ ]
come on my show we'll have a nice little
talk
and look maybe your channel go look it's
gonna help only gonna help your channel
right
so let's do it we'll be completely
respectful
you're not gonna get you're not gonna
get ambushed or anything no one's gonna
[ __ ] in your [ __ ] shower
and any of that stuff okay we're gonna
have a nice fun conversation i think
it'll be fun
and at the end of it maybe we'll become
good friends and maybe you know maybe
you had a reason for killing those ducks
i don't really know
so that's my take look i i actually have
to i cannot finish this i'm sorry
and normally i would keep going but i
actually have to do something but i'm
going to say this
we're going to finish there's two more
videos obviously going to finish these
on monday but however
i'm sure and please jj correct me if i'm
wrong that this coverage will be
continuing on uh d
live dot tv slash jj stoner i mean
i don't really wanna i i got other stuff
okay so how about this jj you free
monday to come back monday
i am definitely free monday okay so
here's what we're gonna do
because we're gonna do on mondays
there's a lot more guys the amount of
stuff that this is just video one
and kitty just gave me a playlist of all
the hits so
so we we will we will be going through
the rest of this
on monday